for a long time we didn't know much
about galaxies just a century ago we
thought that the Milky Way was all there
was scientists called it our island
universe for them no other galaxies
existed then in 1924 astronomer Edwin
Hubble changed all that Hubble was
observing the universe with the most
advanced telescope at the time the
100-inch hooker on Mount Wilson near Los
Angeles deep and the night sky he saw
fuzzy blobs of light that were far far
away he realized they weren't individual
stars at all
they were whole cities of stars galaxies
way beyond the Milky Way
[Music]
astronomers had an existential shock in
one year we went from the universe being
the Milky Way galaxy to a universe of
billions of galaxies
Hubble had made one of the greatest
discoveries in the history of astronomy
the universe contains not just one but a
great number of galaxies
this is the Whirlpool Galaxy it has two
giant spiral arms and contains around
160 million stars
and galaxy m87 a giant elliptical galaxy
it's one of the oldest in the universe
and the stars glow gold
and this is the sombrero galaxy it has a
huge glowing core with a ring of gas and
dust all around it
you